what's up guys michael here to talk
about why learning to control your
emotions is probably better than using
an army of titans to kill a lot of
people today we're taking a
philosophical look at part two of season
four of attack on titan now i already
covered the first part of season four
focusing on the philosophy of
anti-natalism so
be sure to check that out too but in
this part of season four plans have
changed and we're now going from a
subtle forced euthanasia plan to a very
unsubtle genocide by titan's plan so are
there any philosophical revelations to
be gleaned from all of this unhinged
rage and violence well for my wisecrack
colleague lux the key might be looking
at it through the perspective of
stoicism stoicism is a philosophical
tradition that holds that if you want to
live a virtuous life you should follow
logical principles rather than unbridled
emotions and feelings sort of like how
you always feel like you can eat five to
six slices of pizza when logically it's
more like two or three with the side of
salad that is if you're a quitter so
cover your napes and step away from the
walls because in this edition of a
philosopher reacts we're going to dig
deep into attack on titan season 4 part
2 to ask can stoicism save us and
spoilers ahead
okay guys before we get into it and i
promise this will just take a second i
wanted to quickly tell you that we've
recently updated and upgraded our
patreon page and i think you should
check it out and there's a lot of really
fun stuff on there we're doing some
extra podcast content where you can hear
from writers and editors and researchers
at wisecrack to hear about the videos
we're making if you like this video what
you'll probably like is a new feature
where i am doing monthly philosophy
office hours where i'm going to dive
deeper into a lot of the philosophical
material that comes up in our videos
talk about the history of philosophy and
most importantly answer questions from
you all our patrons so if you haven't
checked it out in a while please do
there will be a link in the description
but now let's get on with the show and
talk about attack on titan okay so part
two of season four picks up where part
one left off meaning things are not
going super well aaron and zeke are on
the verge of carrying out their
euthanasia plan which we talked about in
our last video on attack on titan but
then after double cross and zeke aaron
gets the power of the founding titan and
goes all out to destroy everyone on the
planet who isn't on parody's island
while aaron is uh
really going for it now some of our
friends and enemies are working together
in a last-ditch effort to stop him from
doing a genocide and so much as aaron
and the jaegerus and of course the
marlians are fueled by negative emotions
our gang of potential heroes has a
chance only if they stop relying on
feelings and instead try to do something
positive by working towards some
genuinely good principles and how do
they do this a little bit of good
old-fashioned stoicism so what is
stoicism usually if someone is described
as stoic
it's like when you're talking about an
old man with no feelings who drinks
whiskey for breakfast and is
inexplicably always chopping wood and
putting it into neatly organized piles
and while that dude obviously rips this
is not quite what the original stoics
were talking about in a general sense
they were descendants in the line of
virtue ethics a school of thought that
began with plato and really found its
legs with aristotle if you're unfamiliar
with the concept aristotle said that
living a virtuous life was all about
orienting your life towards happiness
now he used the term telos which means
aim to describe the way in which virtue
gives us an aim for our activity when he
says happiness he's not referring to a
general feeling of contentment or
swimming in good vibes and great oldies
instead he's talking about eudaimonia
which is a type of happiness that has to
do with human flourishing i.e living
your absolute best life the stoics
turned this idea of virtue into a
full-on philosophy of life and it wasn't
really focused on heady concepts or
metaphysical ponderings but about actual
human existence
who would have thought a philosophy
that's just about living your actual
life now for the stoics the point of
philosophy was basically being good at
life
as pierre hadeau describes it for the
stoic then doing philosophy meant
practicing how to live that is how to
live freely and consciously
consciously and that we pass beyond the
limits of individuality to recognize
ourselves as a part of the reason
animated cosmos freely and that we give
up desiring that which does not depend
on us and is beyond our control so as to
attach ourselves only to what depends on
us actions which are just in conformity
with reason okay um enough about long
dead greek dudes
let's check out what happens when
emotions kind of tear zeke and aaron
apart
foreign
that sucks you know you find your
long-lost brother and think you have
someone you can like love and trust now
obviously
this right here is not stoicism but it's
important to help us understand stoicism
the same way that like watching blood on
the asphalt in driver's ed helps you
learn about not speeding up the lover's
lane without your seatbelt on and also
why necking can and will get you
pregnant now what we just saw is
basically the opposite of stoicism and
zeke and aaron and of course like
everyone else on the show are being
driven completely by passion namely
anger and hatred and for the stoics
being virtuous wasn't simply about
orienting your life around goodness it
was also about control in particular
controlling your passions and emotions
so if a committed stoic was driving on
the freeway after a horrible day at work
and got cut off by someone with a baby
on board sticker on their car they
wouldn't be overcome with the passion to
flick them off with a burning hatred
also babies are bad drivers this is
because stoicism necessitates
controlling passions and emotions so
that one acts solely on virtuous
principles and while giving someone the
double birds while using your knees to
drive the car it's fun it's not virtuous
what we see in both zeke and aaron's
plans and their outcomes is what happens
when one's thoughts and actions are
dictated by emotion and passion and not
reason and deliberation so let's check
out a really interesting scene where we
flash back to one of the many scenarios
that seem to be at the heart of aaron's
rage
[Music]
[Applause]
any political leader that does that move
they're never good now here we get a
flashback sequence that gives us a
little bit of insight into aaron's
initial decision to sow the seeds of his
genocide plan and it shows us what
happens when a motion takes over now
aaron and the scouts are visiting marley
to try ice cream for the first time and
get blitzed at a migrant camp and forge
a plan of peace with the subjects of
your mere protection group however
during this meeting of the assembly the
leader of the protection group basically
goes full hitler when he calls for the
citizens of paradise to be exterminated
this political fervor is very unstoic
and that it's both fueled by emotion
namely hatred isn't oriented around any
type of virtue things like courage
justice or moderation and is operating
on the assumption that one group of
humans is fundamentally inferior to the
other in contrast stoics would recognize
that nature has not given us that memo
this right here is why logic was crucial
to the stoics and i'm not talking about
the type of formal logic that's the
philosophical equivalent of algebra
thank god but a simple logical
deliberation on whether or not a
specific position or set of actions is
virtuous again following in the
aristotelian tradition the stoics
consider logical deliberation to be a
crucial part of virtue that's because
unbridled emotions can easily sway one
two extremes while logical consideration
helps us arrive at more moderate and
thus more virtuous positions and here we
see the scouts come into the assembly
hoping to arrive at a logical position
but all they observe is genocidal fervor
and it seems like this is a sort of
final straw for aaron as his response to
the marlins hatred is just a much much
much gnarlier hatred aimed back at them
now another important aspect of stoicism
is that even when you're not doing
xenophobia for laws living a good life
isn't just about seeking out things that
are pleasurable for you things like
wealth health comfort and is this toilet
paper or cake and in the wake of aaron's
victory jean is put in a position to
weigh his individual comfort versus
virtuous principles so let's check that
out real quick
[Music]
now here john is tempted by the
opportunity to retire and live a good
life as a hero of parodies now in one
sense it might seem like pursuing health
and wealth aren't bad things it might
even be virtuous
assuming that you're not overtly hurting
anyone in the process but according to
the stoics something can only truly be
virtuous when it's also just meaning
that the ends we pursue
don't make life shorter for others or
happen at their expense now
jean could just hang out and enjoy the
spoils of war but in doing so he's
basically going to be sleeping in a bed
built by genocide
which tend to have really scratchy
sheets that are soaked with tears of
anguish and despair now we see in the
wake of aaron's plan that flock and the
jaegerus got drunk with power pretty
quickly but those like jon who are able
to leave are operating more in line with
stoicism as they're pursuing virtues
like justice courage and moderation
above pursuing power and wealth okay
speaking of being virtuous
what would the stoics think
about you feeding someone
to your mom
to make her live i don't know let's find
out because someone does that
this is so this is very gnarly
[Music]
do speak louder
[Music]
now who among us wouldn't be tempted to
feed a human child to our mother if it
would bring her back to life but even if
we can kind of relate to what connie is
doing here it's clear that again he's in
this situation because he's unable to
deal with the pain of losing his mother
and this pain has led to a plan that's
not super logical and is definitely not
moral but you know just when it seems
like he's about to drop human food into
his mom's titan mouth hole he's
motivated to do something good when he
saves armin from doing suicide via titan
mom this seems to snap connie out of his
plan to sacrifice falco and helps him
realize the virtue of doing what's right
even if it doesn't directly benefit
one's passions okay in the next episode
hanji has a similar moment of
seemingly stoic clarity let's check that
out
my
that's okay you're allowed to raise your
voice when you're saying the genocide is
wrong that's a good life rule you can
always be loud okay so here we see hanji
coming to a sort of crossroads between
passion and logic as she realizes that
genocide of any sort is categorically
wrong
plus much of the ideology perpetuated by
marley is equally driven by emotions
like hatred and fear and not by any
logical reasons and surely not for any
virtuous reasons this is the point of
the season where we transition from
seeing a majority of our characters
unable to control their emotions to one
where they start to sacrifice their own
individual interests for the sake of a
greater good okay let's skip ahead just
a little bit in the same episode
[Music]
this is some real spit right now
[Music]
come on join the team join the team
johnson
[Music]
yeah
okay so after hanji has her own come to
stoic jesus moment she's working to
convince john to follow suit and after
just being tempted by flock with a cushy
life the new jageris empire choosing
virtue for jean means sacrificing a
probably pleasurable existence for the
sake of a difficult and likely deadly
journey to do what is right and here
jean isn't just choosing to go against
his former jaegers comrades he's also
choosing to work with a new group to
actively fight against aaron and in the
process he's choosing principles over
comfort okay so um there's a scene that
happens maybe maybe someone will pop it
in here where after
john decided to be a good guy he almost
beats reiner to death and it seems like
maybe he's not gonna go with our gang
but look what happens the next morning
so casual
if any of you ever beat me almost to
death the next morning don't like bully
me it's just a lot but we talked before
about john presumably being anti-aaron's
genocide which is good and way more
virtuous than
supporting genocide but it doesn't mean
he's gone full stoic just yet that's
because in the scene right before this
rage motivates him into trying to beat
reiner to death so you know stoicism has
a bit of a learning curve but at least
he's on the right path but also don't
don't beat people up it's not good okay
before we wrap up i want to look at one
more clip this is from the penultimate
episode of the season
it's when things are not really going
well
for our friends we're trying to stop
aaron but let's watch
this rough hang
that's real saving the people whose
names you never know
[Music]
foreign
okay
that's tense so earlier in the season we
saw that up until this point annie had
largely been motivated by a hatred
towards her adoptive father which
evolved into a love for him and a desire
to rescue him from the rumbling now here
after realizing her motivating aim of
saving her father is no longer possible
she seems like she kind of wants to like
give up but she recommits to the cause
because it's the right thing to do even
though it's very hard and there's an
underlying melancholy here and that's
clear the odds are very very very much
against our gang right here but this
right here brings up another aspect of
stoicism which is the point of pursuing
virtue
isn't to simply bring about a desirable
result the point is to act in accordance
with universal nature i.e a sense of
natural justice which will make you
happy even if you don't actually get the
thing you were aiming at in this case it
seems clear that even if our mini
resistance is destined to fail
they will still experience a type of
happiness in continuing to do what's
right it's not dissimilar from emmanuel
kant's moral philosophy in which right
intention matters as much if not more
than the right result as the season ends
with aaron's founding titan and his
titan army stomping out human
civilization it at least seems like the
best our gang of resistors can hope for
is doing what's virtuous even if it
doesn't work out and this relates to
another part of stoicism namely that
it's not only about learning how to live
it's about learning how to die as well
seneca here plagiarized by montaigne
said
he who has learned to die has unlearned
how to serve and as epictetus said keep
death before your eyes every day and
then you will never have any abject
thought or any excessive desire
all of this according to hedo means that
we should remain present as if every
moment is paradoxically our first and
our last okay so does part two of season
four of attack on titan give us a master
class and how to become stoics not
really but much of the season shows us
what can happen when hatred anger and
fear take priority over logical
deliberation in the pursuit of virtue
this helps us understand what the stoics
saw as an undesirable and unvirtuous way
to live towards the end of the season we
start to see how moving beyond negative
passions and emotions to approach things
from a more logical perspective leads a
group of characters to overcome their
hatred for the sake of the common good
and this gets at the coolest thing about
stoicism
it's really a philosophy of life the
stories weren't primarily focused on
heady like making metaphysical arguments
about the nature of being or logically
deliberating on the nature of truth
they think philosophically for the sake
of living a good life
something that puts them in touch with
the spirit of socrates it also makes
them predecessors of the 19th and 20th
century existential philosophers for
whom philosophy is primarily about how
we live life and make sense of our
existence and not merely about how we
understand things in a detached sense
and if you're interested in learning
more about this tradition i can't
recommend pierre hadeau's philosophy as
a way of life highly enough so access
your library card titan and check it out
but what do you guys think can attack on
titan teach us about the virtues of the
stoics
or are we just watching genocidal
maniacs have a field day let us know
what you think in the comments and
definitely let me know if there are
other shows movies or games that you
think warrant some philosophical
attention thanks as always to our
amazing patrons for all your support and
if you haven't checked out our patreon
page in a while we have a lot of great
new content going up so give it a peek
hit that subscribe button like you're
stoically blowing up your own boat and
don't forget to ring that bell as always
thanks for watching later
okay we'll we'll stop that one right
there but um you know not really good
advice for
like how to be a good
brother um i think you know but um i'm
just waiting for the prompter to get
here so they're gonna put this in the
video